today we're in Riyadh Saudi Arabia in
Saudi Arabia is a very fascinating land
a lot of wealth a lot of mega malls a
lot of expensive cars but there's
another side of the story there is the
other side of the tracks so today I'm
gonna take you to that side to see what
the so called ghetto or tough hood of
Riyadh looks like I want to see the
dangerous on day money they take my
money in my camera tip okay so bring me
there please
see I thought Riyadh didn't have a real
dangerous neighborhood but it does but
does this help I'm wearing this it helps
maybe this book doesn't help this is
where the danger area starts right here
feeding is that like gangs you have
gangs here y'all games of gangsters
King nighttime is dangerous she's
dangerous
she's not dangerous these guys are
dangerous huh no no don't drop me there
keep going this is such a contrast bud
home yeah old style
mohamad this is a proper tour where were
you taking us I could go desert their
homes out here
no other homes at which the neighborhood
yes Maserati Maserati is not in the bad
neighborhood
are there guns here or no
police are strong here yeah
put it down he's pissed go go go go yeah
guys I'm not putting the camera up when
these guys are staring us hardcore it's
just flirting the line of doing
something quit steal take pictures here
did you see those last guys back there
yeah he was he was yelling and waving
his hand this is properly hardcore those
guys are yelling - yeah we go canvass
the streets and then get out of here we
don't want to stay too long huh no
thanks all criminals I'm sure there's
some non criminals go left go left
so guys back there some groups of guys
hanging out just hardcore staring maybe
knives hardcore staring like right at us
waving hands dude so so I don't want to
put the camera on their face because
they'll get in their cars and probably
chase their asses down I just a feeling
I get here
so this is one of the rougher looking
neighborhoods I've ever been in to be
honest we've seen the bad sides wanna
Sade's Mexico City Salam alaikum
shukran Messi Messi Ronaldo
Pele those kids were nice they had a
smile than the then it got weird with
the camera
and then their buddies started walking
closer
I wouldn't say I like it but it's I
think it's important to see those stuff
to be honest I think it's important to
know the full truth and like not just
show I show mostly the positive nice
things I think it's good to balance that
out with the reality
the other reality right yeah it's too
much engine it's not good no good don't
go in there
it's not nobody no go
and yeah guys I can't give it all to you
some hard looks
it would be one thing walking around
here I think I think it could be okay
but walking around with a camera is a
guarantee we get screwed where I get
screwed classic
he's on drugs
you know something's wrong with him
Mohamad do we got any more places here
is that it more boy
let's get some tea yeah so I was just
purchasing some Goods and this man came
up with a shopping bag and just started
following and filling it up very nice
very nice to me brother thank you Oh
banana banana yeah very good service
thank you what's your name
sell me my book thank you brother
bye-bye huh
Peter Peter hello mallamma
I have no idea why I Muhammad stopped
here
there he is what's going on Mohammed
another
you need one
inshallah God willing got it you bought
it
mohamad you said the Saudis are bad
drivers but what's up with your car here
look at this look at this they hit you
there they hit you there you did nothing
they hit you there too
hit him there
so you did none of these crashes
this is your brother yeah I'm happy yeah
he's got a nice tote Pakistani stuff you
open you thought I was sorry you a
surprise surprise we're going to the a
dangerous neighborhood you come in yeah
he picked me up a new Mohammed you have
such a weak handshake brother that's
that's a proper handshake
why is your dear sheikh so limp ladies
what's the question
yeah you better my girlfriend's here
she's not gonna be doing this room man
yes she's not a baby I want to say hi hi
hi Natalia they say hi Natalia
I miss my high Natalia Natalia
Feli really Nardo footballers out what
do you say it right now but football oh
dude I had nothing to say to these guys
they were smiling and then I showed the
camera and they looked like they were
gonna kill me and so I dropped football
names and then I brought things around
I'm not a football guy I knew a few
names it was an icebreaker bro
with the guys the last name is
neighborhood let's walk around a little
let's let's stop yeah
we saw three what three bad
neighborhoods yeah this one not so bad
yeah you can take it
you may talk to my girlfriend again you
can touch the county Oh daddy how are
you hello do the newest Pakistani
vlogger finding is good maybe your June
July I'm asking me you're coming son is
very hard this time is red it is very
good look at the camera and tell you how
do you feel we go get some young brother
sorry really good brother
kill me kill me kill me kill me ya heart
brother heart hey guys oh so he's giving
us Salaam alaikum
[Music]
Salam alaikum Peter it's okay oh
salaam-alaikum Peter Peter
yeah right Rajib Peter good good you
liked it I loved it yeah you you take
two days with this cream it's both
powerful this test you guys got the
shisha set up nice nice shisha Sarah
this is a very cool room he said to
Quran
[Music]
that's nice that's really nice
very power and any powerful well this
makes you strong yeah vhagar
[Laughter]
and then this is just black this is just
black tea people like your nose outside
because mr. Peter how can you feel yeah
that style because now everybody go with
you
so he feel this smell you know they
bring you in you know they bring you
into their home this this yeah what are
the brother curse that you you say to
one place okay you spend now today night
uh-huh you see more friends come here
okay I think 15 or 20 had to have here
so talking to enjoyment time span
mentally relax it's beautiful and you
you guys don't even know him he doesn't
know me obviously and they just invite
us him it's really special brother
good because no I love you I love you
too man
thank you it's a hard job
yeah you wish you never met me huh